[Music]
well you say you want to do this
without a job changes
adrenaline and rage I may never change
my tire compressing all the stress has
my oh my chest running out of breath my
name above me
[Music]
Stud before he was the Muhammad Ali of
the Dawa no bro Muhammad Ali is the
Muhammad Ali of Dawa he is still
learning the ropes do you think you'll
get up I hope so if you told me would be
in this position 12 months ago I'd bit
in your ear off hmm
maybe you've bitten more than you can
chew nah bro we've had over 4,000
Shahada is all around the world create
more than 60 teams and give endow to
over 40 countries Wow
al hamdulillah well event events
lectures workshops seminars exhibitions
over a thousand thousand yes sir
dowel material almost four hundred
thousand and distribute to a hundred
countries four hundred thousand they're
doing better than this day start how
many outreach special do you guys up 36
36 and what about this guy he'll be 37
inshallah do you think he's ready to
rumble I think so mmm-hmm he jab jab
wake up stay with me he jab he jabbed
wake up bro stay with me
wake up stay with me bro wake up he jab
wake up bro come on hijab come on bro
wake up stay with me champions are made
in each other champions are made from
something deep inside them deep inside
dream vision desire you have to have
that last minute stamina have to be a
little faster
you have to have the skill and the will
will must be strongly skilled
[Music]
prophet peace be upon him said the
struggler is the one who strives in
obedience to God he job wake up bro stay
with me
wake up
[Music]
[Applause]